oh my god dude this you got the wrong
house dude that's so good that laugh is
the greatest Stephen here yeah you got
the wrong house the way the [__] sure
laugh but the insecurity behind
it I knew this was a ripoff a rip
off okay what are you looking for a
Steven
no I am Stephen I'm looking for uh
Fifi a dog Fifi dude the guy responded
to someone named Fifi and thought it
wasn't aruse yeah you got the wrong
house here it
comes here it comes so you don't want to
have sex
[Music]
tonight last ditch effort sir
dude uh well you're a voice you're a
chick
so uh sir my husband's in the living
room with the
gun huh
ah huh the best reaction of all time
[Laughter]
okay have a good night
understood
so seething dude this
guy Stephen
here you got the wrong
house that's the best the last I knew
this was a
ripoff a ripoff you know a
RI gave somebody [__] hundreds of
dollars and said yes show up and ask for
Fifi okay what are you looking for a
stepen no I am Stephen I'm looking for
uh Fifi the pauses is great yeah you got
the wrong
house the wind so you don't want to have
sex
tonight last ditch
effort uh sir my husband's in the living
room with the
gun
huh okay
understood huh okay understood how much
I I love the Packers unbelievable dude